hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
one particularly important topic that is
discussed in seneca's on anger book one
is the relationship between anger and
Punishment a lot of people think that
anger is needed in order to punish
wrongdoing so that if you're not angry
particularly as somebody who has
Authority and can punish then you're
maybe not going to do your job
adequately you're not going to
take the wrong doers the violent those
who prey on others and do what you ought
to to them you'll be too lenient you'll
let them go and they'll pray on others
and Seneca wants to shift the way in
which we look at these matters what he's
saying pertains just as much I think to
the present as it did to his own time
when this was a significant issue so he
asked how should we deal humanely in a
spirit of humanity with wrongdoing and
with the people who are doing wrong
wrong doers and he you know he begins by
looking at something that theophrasta
says a good man cannot help but be
angered by evils and he says that's not
the way to to approach these matters
first off you're going to be angry at
everybody all the time but what's more
important is to think about how it is
that we actually do change people by
punishing them and so punishment is not
meant to be you could say this will
sound a little bit silly merely punitive
right it's not merely
retributive it's not just about hurting
the person who did the wrong thing
it's oriented towards making things
better towards he actually uses the word
at several points healing so he says
um
how much more truly human to regard
wrongdoers with a gentle and paternal
cast of mind not to persecute them but
to summon them back when a person is
wandering through the fields and
ignorance or the way it's better to
guide him to the right path than to
banish him banish him from the path
altogether so he's got these two
metaphors guiding them to the right path
and you know bringing them back into
what into the community of human persons
now this won't be possible with every
single offenders we'll get to in just a
moment but in many cases that is
possible so he continues and says the
wrongdoer should be corrected both by
admonition admonition is warning
censuring them telling them they're
doing the wrong thing and he also says
by by force
softly and roughly and he must now this
is a really key point he must be made
better if this is possible
for the sake of two different parties
their own sake right you don't want a
person who's continually doing the wrong
thing and so if you can apply
punishments in such a ways to help them
realize that they've been screwing up
and they don't want to live that kind of
life going forward do that but also for
the sake of others and here we you know
should probably interject that for
stoics like Seneca Justice is indeed a
virtue and Justice is the virtue that
has to do with how we live life together
with others in community
so making the unjust person at least a
little bit more just that's part of what
punishment is supposed to accomplish for
Seneca so getting angry is that actually
going to help out he says
who feels angry at the one he's healing
if you adopt this point of view you're
going to view your administration of
justice as a healing process a process
of helping people become more whole less
damaged and so he says now of course if
they cannot be straight set straight
nothing in them is gentle or offers
ground for Hope well then we have to
remove them from the company of Mortals
and you know that might be the only
available means to put a stop to their
wickedness even then he says you can do
this without hatred without in Latin
audio right so you can
do things that that heal them you can
also if need be eliminate them take them
out of the community altogether and he
says why should I hate the person who I
most benef fit at the moment when I
separate him from himself surely no one
hates his own limbs when he amputates
them does he that's not anger but a
pitiable form of healing and he's got a
few other examples we destroy rabid dogs
we kill a Fierce and untameable ox and
Slaughter sick livestock unless they
infect the the herd we snuff out
monstrous births and even drown children
if they're born crippled or deformed
it's not anger but reason razio the The
Faculty that we have as human beings two
as he says segregate the useful from the
sound and he says nothing is less
appropriate to the person who is
punishing than anger why punishment is
all the more conducive to correction if
it's imposed as an act of considered
judgment so if we want to punish
effectively we can't be angry when we're
doing it we can't be motivated by by
hatred and he wants to go on and say not
only should we try to avoid this there's
there's actually no need for anger or
for hatred in order to punish correctly
he says when it comes to restraining
those who stray and commit crimes there
is no need for the agent of punishment
to be angry
why not well because becoming angry is
actually as he says a failure a screw-up
a damage case for the mind so if you're
going to be somebody who is
administering Justice You're engaging in
judgment and you know sifting the case
and figuring out what kind of punishment
would be appropriate
why do you have to be a wrongdoer to
punish wrongdoers isn't that kind of
silly and you know seneca's pointing out
the
incongruity there we won't say
necessarily hypocrisy although he could
have done that as well so he says um
what if somebody responds shall I not be
angry at a bandit then so abandoned is
somebody who is you know using violence
taking other people's stuff probably
getting away with it uh should I not be
angry at a poisoner now poisoner that's
about the lowest of the low that you can
get among murderers and he says no
I don't become angry with myself when I
let out my own blood every kind of
punishment I apply I apply by way of
Remedy and then he goes through this
interesting passage where he talks he's
sort of like going through a bunch of
cases and saying okay this sort of case
I would apply this kind of Remedy and
they're getting more and more and more
serious so he starts out by saying
you're still in the first stages of
going wrong your slips aren't serious
but they are frequent what do I do then
reproof I say oh you're doing the wrong
thing first in private right I take you
aside and I'm like hey man you're
screwing up you got to knock this off
right and then published abroad meaning
you know making it uh it could be social
media for us for Seneca it'd be like you
know somebody saying something in public
or maybe putting up a notice and that
might be enough to correct you what if
you're worse off you've already gone too
far to be healed just by words well then
we apply more painful remedies disgrace
we censure you we humiliate you in some
way
um you have something stronger burned
into you something you'll feel you'll be
sent into Exile in your case the
wickedness is already firm firmly set
and needs harsher remedies oh well then
we'll put you in the public stocks right
so so that's also humiliation or we'll
put you in prison and then he goes on
and he you know raises the stakes he
says your mind which weaves a growing
web of crime is beyond healing you need
no motives to set you off but wrongdoing
is already sufficiently strong motive
for doing wrong well
in that case there's not much we can do
with you we could put you in prison but
you're going to come out of it you know
no better for it you're not gonna it's
not gonna be a remedy it's just going to
be something that you endure and so he
says well you've drunk deep of
wickedness and you've so steeped your
guts in it that it cannot be expelled
except with those very guts so in in a
case like that we're gonna have to kill
you you know
um and he says that we'll put at your
disposal the only good that remains for
you
death death is indeed a remedy for some
people who are so far gone and Seneca
says at this point
you don't have to be angry as you're
going through these stages at any point
you don't need to have anger motivating
you to do the right thing and apply the
remedies he says
um
sometimes killing is the best sort of
pity if I'd entered an Army's infirmary
or rich man's house as a medical expert
I would not have prescribed the same
remedy for those suffering from diverse
ailments I've been recruited to heal the
community I see so many Minds offer a
range of vices medication should be
sought according to each individual's
illness so being a good judge being a
proper Punisher means thinking these
things through an anger would interfere
with that he also talks about being like
the law now this is very interesting
because so there's a couple things going
on here that that are all connected
together one is Seneca you know
throughout this work is criticizing
Aristotle and yet Aristotle himself in
uh the politics and you know also in
other places is going to say that the
law should should rule not human beings
why because the law is reason without
desire or passion right the law is in
certain respects more we would say today
objective and
Seneca is saying you shouldn't just
apply the law
you should be like the law how does the
law actually work the law doesn't get
angry at anybody because the law isn't
something that feels passions like that
right he says that
um you know I will order not angrily but
strictly that the procedure is
prescribed by law be carried out right
known iratus said severes being strict
being a stickler for the requirement
that is being imposed and you know he
goes on as well and he says that
um you know the the good person is going
to behave like the law in these cases do
you mean the law strikes you as angry at
those who it doesn't know who it hasn't
seen who it hopes will not exist no we
must take on the cast of Mind proper to
the law which is wrathful not wrathful
but resolved constituent right it it
stands there in place a little bit later
on uh skipping ahead in the work he
tells us that whoever is free of anger
doesn't do any of these things that are
you know typical of anger when imposing
the penalty that each person deserves
often now notice so he said that we
should be sticklers we should be strict
we can also sometimes
exercise a bit of discretion so he goes
on and he says
he sometimes releases a person who's
misdeedia is caught out if the person's
regret gives good reason to Hope if the
judge sees the wickedness is not
deep-seated but sticks as they say to
the surface of the Mind he'll Grant a
suspended sentence that will harm
neither the recipient nor The Giver
sometimes he'll apply a lighter Reign to
important crimes than to lesser ones if
the former were committed through a slip
rather than cruelty whereas the latter
concealed the stealthy and habitual
cunning so what he's talking about there
is proportionate and prudent punishment
or penalty sometimes we need to exercise
a bit of what Aristotle called Equity at
biakia like where you relax the law or
we often today call this discretion or
even Mercy
and the point here is that well you
can't do that if you're motivated by
anger right so we want to be rational
calm prudent as we punish people not
angry not hating them and then we can
make punishments work
for what they're supposed to do namely
to heal and fix the person who is being
punished and to protect others
from their future
misdeeds it's a much more future
oriented present oriented than past
oriented way of looking at punishment
and so Seneca thinks that anger and
hatred wind up being completely out of
place in the person who is punishing not
only does anger not help you punish
better it actually is going to get in
the way